[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
bin gerade mit meinem team in berlin
wir besuchen hier die ifa 2009 10 auf
der ifa gibt es immer alle technischen
neuheiten alle innovationen und die
ganzen erfindungen werden hier praktisch
vorgestellt und wie in den letzten
jahren bin ich bei vorstand und in der
küche und koche und backe für meine
besucher aber nicht nur das es gibt
wirklich ganz viele tolle innovationen
dieses jahr auf der messe viel
nützliches viel unterhaltsames aus murat
wird zum beispiel ein koreanischer
wischmopp roboter vertreter und ein
echter barista ich habe gelernt dass
sport auch spaß machen kann und unser
absolutes messehighlight ist unsere
eigene app die kostenlos ist und die
zeit der ifa online ist also kommt man
mit ich zeige euch jetzt die ifa 2009 10
[Musik]
das ist ganz cool es ist ihre sitze und
zwar ist es in echtzeit
ich spreche etwas unruhige zeit
übersetzt richtig wenn die kommt schon
mal ganz kurz zisch am eigens bräuchte
stoße nicht mal ein ja irgendwas stimmt
da ist es frage das heißt ich spreche
etwas runter und herr horst in echtzeit
in roitzsch zum beispiel sprechen mehr
im monat
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist ja perfekt bin im
arkadas schon günther wieland
mein freund günther ist ein tier gehört
hallo herzlich willkommen zu meiner
torten welt heute zeige ich euch ein
richtig leckeres schokoladen rezept und
dafür braucht ihr nur drei eier 200
gramm zucker und 300 gramm mehl
die wahlkarte verstärkt
fiat denn ja darüber setzt meine rezepte
eins zu eins was das gerät kostet knapp
300 euro hat eine integrierte sim-karte
und ihr könnt dann praktisch überall auf
der ganzen welt alle sprachen übersetzen
sollte also ich bin deswegen wirklich
genial
ich würde das ding auf jeden fall den
leuten fehle es ist schnell weg dazu
dankeschön einer wunderbar mitnehmen war
vor dem spiel sehen uns am 18 segway das
kann sie noch klaus eck regionen g und
fahren der runde bin ich den losen kann
wächst was die innovatives finden kann
mir etwas ausprobieren weil ich ihn mir
abgeben
perfekt sei murat hier stand her
ich hab dich hier angemeldet ist eine
halbe stunde
[Musik]
nach rechts ich werde den npa ist wie
mario kart 50 holen ich hab mich hier
raus wie mache ja aber ich sehe aus wie
donkey kong habe jetzt nachgefragt ist
den kostet momentan 1000 euro will ich
hole wo er ist eines elektro läuft ist
sehr stabil also 1000 euro findet ist
eigentlich viel oder zu finden damit der
feuerraum gesteuert dass man damit auf
der straße fährt oder ist auf der straße
fahren und das coole ist das ding ist
franz eckert da war auf 10 km h
gedrosselt normalerweise platz 24 km h
ich will ja auch ein bisschen leichter
bei mir wäre ich mit 30 km h drauf
bringen strikt ab
[Musik]
okay ich hab was
ja was völlig verrückt dass gefahr jetzt
mal ohne spaß das zu erklären aber wenn
es gar nicht
[Musik]
manchmal ist das ist mal ganz blöd was
ist ein kissen zu streichen oder dem
schwanz weg
knot ist die katze also kannst in zwei
verschiedene farben haben
ich weiß gar nicht was heißt hier gruppe
ist das schwarz ich mache mir auch
gerade gedanken über die zielgruppe
dort hinein dollar 101 103 109 jahren
wird das team schwanz
ich habe da hinten noch was cooleres
gesehen der hilfsbereite mann
analysieren er analysiert jetzt deinen
arsch und ich bin der
schimmelbeseitigung analysieren da wird
man schenkt er stirbt bald das wird
anscheinend schon in der met nicola aus
der wohnbau ein buch gepackt haben
[Gelächter]
vorhergesagt dass irgendwann fast kein
computer dann hast du einmal 1000 aber
dann ist es zu wissen
alles rot
das ist ja ein paar würstchen gegessen
also eigentlich alles was schlecht ist
also du kannst es dann über mehrere
wochen monaten analysieren und du kannst
praktisch immer sein essen eintragen ok
und dann merkt er das gerät okay wenn du
das und das und das ersatzteil körper
nicht gut und dann kann so zum beispiel
dieses insulin was sie zum brot zum
beispiel drin ist und den zwiebeln in
getreide und das ist das was dir jetzt
mal zuschlägt und probierst du das und
weiß genau okay das sind jetzt
lebensmittel die du mehr meiden sollte
okay das heißt gut marvel schauen sie
mal rein vielleicht jetzt obwohl die
deutsche übersetzung und jetzt verlassen
stand bevor das gab das will ich hab da
was für dich gefunden und zwar dass ich
wissen was ich auch die hummer
revolution und zwar das ding du es dir
hier hinlegen oder weißt du wenn du aufs
klo gehen muss richtig aber es ist auch
gut für ältere menschen genau das ist
gut für ältere menschen wie war es für
dich
unbestritten ist ja voll zu tun also ich
finde es nicht finde es aber tatsächlich
innovativ denn es gibt ja viele ältere
menschen die merken einfach nicht wenn
die blase voll ist ja und das gibt mir
dann einfach ein signal
also ich finde das sollte schon dinge
blase school findet man viele merken das
heißt du machst dir dann als ältere
menschen zu hause das hab ich jetzt pass
auf das habe ich jetzt ganz ehrlich habe
ich nie verstanden gehabt aber jetzt
kann man ja eine ganz ganz gute idee
hardware zb seine eltern zu hause pflegt
finde ich weiß es schon länger ist so
bist du bist wohl leider so aus spaß
gemacht habe gelogen
ich glaube dreieinhalb millionen in
deutschland
leiter dem kontinent eine ganz gute
lösung wenn sich auch schon hier habe es
jetzt nicht ausprobiert weiß nicht wie
es geht
aber richtig cool ist
lassen so drin und wenn jetzt zum
beispiel hier mehr schokolade auf den
boden fällt und dass das flüssige ja
denn ich habe neulich einen beitrag
gelesen
der hieß der sonos katastrophe
es war der katarer google tv oder ein
pärchen in amerika die alten großen hund
in la plata und der hund hat halt in die
ecke des hauses gekettet war weg und der
saugroboter der ist einfach das
filmorchester überhaupt hat es in der
ganzen wohnung verteilt über teppich
oder ein muster in den boden rein
gemacht und nach ungefähr einen tag oder
einen halben tag kommt die familie nach
hause also ganze haus war ziemlich
lässig oder schmutzig und eigentlich mit
wem man saugroboter aber es hat mich
voll abgeschreckt aber jetzt fiel mir
das mal vor ob das hier funktionieren
muss war das ist ja früher haben wir die
staubsauger roboter nur gesagt und jetzt
tun sie auch zwischen er zeigt es auch
er kenne keine hey das ist ok das café
ist profi und zwar das heißt es copy
heißt es ist kaffee passt ja gar kein
übersetzer ladenbau geht übersetzen
jetzt nicht verbaut
aber es
so markus aus ganz coole geschichte und
ich will ja bestens funktioniert
wirklich und das merkt erst mit kaffee
gemacht
schließlich ist man dran ob es nach
kaffee und kaffee so handlich und chemie
so möchte sie war zuschauen würde es nie
gehabt wahnsinn eine weltneuheit
[Musik]
wahnsinn oder unglaublich was die
koreanische denke ich ja drauf hat bis
dahin bringen möchten sie eins kaufen
jetzt was ganz interessantes für kinder
und zwar ist es ein roboter dem kinder
selber zusammenbauen und selber
programmieren können und dann können sie
einfach ihren eigenen roboter erschaffen
zb den roboter frauen der immer die
blumen gießt oder einen roboter braun
der dann im ventilator ist oder zum
beispiel einer dabei beim vorbeigehen
immer zu winkt also ziemlich cool
vor allem können die kinder dann ein
bisschen was technisches machen
sie können das programmieren lernen und
dann lassen wir es sein so ein bisschen
wie albert einstein leben
torwart
ich habe da vorne noch was cooles
entdeckt da kann es zum beispiel com
ich war
statt vor probiert es mal aus dass die
noch ausliefern ja das sieht ganz ganz
schön aus ist auch ein ganz ganz gutes
gerät sieht aus wie beim mini wo bist du
hinaus wie die kollegin die das nicht
vorher ja aber das geht vorbei ist es
mal aus mal schauen wo hast du ja auch
noch den kühlkammern seien nämlich kein
licht auf das was ich glaube ich habe zu
kurzen oberkörper ja woran liegt es wie
kann gar nichts zu unterfüttern
mein gott die haben sagt franzen
probiert hat funktioniert bei mir ganz
einstellen
man genießt jetzt aus wie bei christian
g sie ist aus als wäre eine
motorradfahrer
das ist ein richtig gegen jahres geräte
unterhalb der physiotherapie verbindet
aber auch in fitnessstudios und ich hab
mir so ein bisschen so preis nicht ein
bisschen um die und die 2000 euro ist ja
wie lange würde es dauern bis erste
aussieht wie das ist genetisch
das kann man nicht trainieren ja ja der
hammer erschlagen
das gibt mir
[Musik]
ich spüre lust und leben noch nie
gespürt ich bin jetzt fitness
bloggerinnen ich mache was trainiert man
echt ganz kraft seine muskulatur
aber es fällt gar nicht so auf die
anstrengung weil man im kopf dabei sein
muss man konzentriert noch schmerzen
habe ich dann muss die karre
[Musik]
und das ist mega cool gesagt das ist
richtig cool also so macht selbst sport
mir spaß und ich bin echt ein sport für
harte strafen sehen dass man 8000 euro
kosten muss ich eine lehre an die
indische organ macht ja verkaufen
[Musik]
ich könnte mich jetzt berühmte pianistin
aus eben
mich hinten aus
dancing einspielen
[Musik]
mein erster gast mein erster gab es noch
meinem herzen kommst herzen
habt ihr mein konzert genossen
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch jetzt die
innovationen bei bosch und werde ich ihr
auch für meine gäste kochen und backen
[Musik]
wie geht's jetzt eine schöne innovation
und zwar die neue integrierte herdplatte
sie habe ich die gleiche bedienung wie
vorher dh die direct select bedienung
super einfach zu bedienen
mit dem vorteil dass ich jetzt den
mulden dürfte hier in der mitte habe
wirklich ganz ganz schmal sieht super
elegant und richtig stylisch aus die
handhabung ist auch ganz einfach und die
reinigung
ich habe hier wirklich nur in ganz
kleinen platzverbrauch und dennoch eine
richtig große leistung das heißt auch
wenn ich hier große töpfe haben mit viel
wasser zum beispiel wird wirklich der
komplette damals alles abgefordert
wenn man sich jetzt sagt mulden lüfter
schön und gut aber ich möchte lieber
eine durchgehende herdplatte haben dann
gibt es auch noch eine andere lösung
ich zeige ich jetzt hier aber erstmal
die herdplatte dies auch richtig schön
denn ich kann mich hier einfach den top
up stellen egal wo die hatten oder
erkennt auch mode top steht schaltet die
zugehörige herdplatte an und sie schadet
auch nicht die zweite generation
wenn ich zum beispiel den großen bräter
haben ich kann auch den top dann einfach
verschieben und die einstellung wird
sofort mit übernommen
das heißt ich muss nicht ständig herum
drücken und hier oben habe ich dann an
der decke den dunstabzug dem kann ich
hier mit dha zunehmend und das ganze
dann automatisch herunter und wieder
höher
so haben wir einfach nicht in der küche
hängen und es sieht echt immer stylisch
und auch du darfst sie gerade auf
höchster stufe und soweit ich das hier
auf der messe beurteilen kann preise
den backofen mit perfect day und perfekt
bewusst sind so habe ich auch zu hause
bisher war es immer so dass ich den
sensor praktische eingeschaltet habe
also wenn ich zum beispiel das stück
fleisch haben wollte habe ich
thermometer eingesteckt und einfach ins
fleisch gestochen und habe meine
kerntemperatur angegeben da oben konnte
mir dann aber immer nicht sagen wann
bestimmte temperatur erreichen das heißt
man stand dann da und hat dann überlegt
okay waren schiebe ich jetzt die
kartoffel noch mit dazu oder waren da
ich die nudeln und jetzt ist die
künstliche intelligenz drin das heißt
die öfter man den ofen benutzt die er
auf der man kurs und rezepte ausprobiert
um so genauer kann der ofen die dann
sagen
ein kuchen oder wann sein fleisch die
perfekte ganze zeit oder gar kein portal
erreicht hat und wann eben das gericht
fertig ist
dass man einfach ganz normalen wie es
vorher eben aufbauen und dann rechnet er
ganz kurz und dann wird angezeigt wann
das gericht fertig
der backofen der landrat auch nicht aus
hier zeige ich euch eine tolle
innovation und zwar dem prozessor von
qualcomm prozessoren gibt es schon aber
der hier ist wirklich so wie ein ganz
normaler top schön groß was 3 liter und
hat einen schönen glatten boden ganz
viele verschiedene einsätze wie mixer
und das kennt man natürlich schon von
anderen herstellern
aber der hat eben schneebesen knethaken
z scheiben mit denen ich obst und gemüse
um andere zutaten hobeln oder raspeln
kann
und das beste daran ist ihr habt hier
dieses display hab da schon rezepte drin
automatikprogramme oder ihr könnt wie
gesagt ganz nah nur erfasst und hierbei
den rezepten
da habt ihr das display in verschiedene
kategorien und können das ganze mit
eurer von connect electric
rund 18 millionen tonnen lebensmittel
werden jedes jahr weggeschmissen das
sind pro minute etwa drei
mülltransporter richtig kraft wie ich
finde und vor allem kann wirklich jeder
was dagegen tun
oftmals schwestern lebensweise nämlich
weg weil man zum einen ich weiß wie man
sie weiterverarbeitet und man hat so
viel eingekauft oder sie werden falsch
gelagert bei der verarbeitung da kann
ich euch weiterhelfen wird bei den
rezepten so viel einkaufen ist immer so
eine sache ruhig sollte man nicht
einkaufen gehen und dann müssen die
lebensmittel einfach richtig gelagert
werden damit sie auch länger frisch
bleiben und eben dadurch auch länger
haltbar gemacht trennen dann könnt ihr
euch im kühlschrank anfangen und ich
zeige euch mal wie das hier funktioniert
69 prozent mehr platz
da passen viele torten rein
vor dessen riesig obwohl er nicht mal so
viel breiter ist als ein anderer kühl
spannend hier hat man einfach eine
feuchtigkeitsregulierung das heißt jedes
lebensmittel wird einfach anders
aufbewahrt und leben länger frisch
gelernt haben
lebensmittel könnt ihr übrigens auch
länger haltbar machen wenn ihr sie
einfriert und wird dieses evakuiert
tapeziert zum beispiel einen beutel der
immer wieder verwendbar ist htc meine
lebensmittel drin
sie findet sie auf der messe unecht aus
lebensmittelverschwendung gründen
da kann ich jetzt hier verschließen und
braucht nur diesen start mixa hier
ich habe einmal den stabmixer auto oder
den aufsatz ihr zum abonnieren
dann hier ansetzen und damit der nicht
ausgezogen
wenn du bis zu 100 prozent vorbei
es ist in die lebensmittel länger
haltbar und ihr habt vor allem auch viel
viel mehr platz im distrikt was zum
beispiel oder auch im kühlschrank
ich war besser als murat
das ziel ist die waschmaschine der
zukunft sieht auch schon ziemlich
futuristisch stylisch aus und zwar habe
die jetzt hier gar keine bedienten und
vermessen man wirklich noch diesen knopf
hier in der mitte und die maschine macht
alles ganz automatisch das heißt ihr
werk macht auch der wäscherei drückt auf
den knopf und das amt
jetzt kommt automatisch ihr könnt
natürlich alles über euer smartphone
kontrollieren und auch einstellen hier
haben wir sogar die möglichkeit an der
trommel also an der tür hier am display
können wir auf alles ablesen ihr könnt
sogar videos abspielt und werden die
waffen schöne welt einfacher tutorials
zum beispiel anschauen sind cool ist
natürlich erstmal noch zukunftsmusik
und ich bin schon gespannt darauf
ankommt und gleichzeitig euch wie man
die tür öffnet
denn dafür ist einfach ein trick mit dem
fuß zum e-auto
michael bosch da ganz praktisch wenn man
gerade einen wäschekorb in der hand hat
erleben sie hier die leisesten
hausgeräte der welt und ein ruheraum
oh ja
kommt ja
vielen dank
er hat gar nichts und alle maschinen
sind gerade am laufen recht leise früher
hat man ja auch die waschmaschine immer
in den keller gepackt es war auch einer
der gründe weil einfach die
waschmaschine immer ziemlich laut war
beim schleudern beim waschen
mittlerweile sind die hausgeräte
wirklich super leise gerade hier im
wohnraum merkt man das wirklich
wunderbar unsere waschmaschine ist
deshalb auch direkt neben unserem
schlafzimmer da wo eben auch die wäsche
entsteht und jetzt hat man auch wirklich
keine stärkere die waschmaschine zu den
wirklich super super leise nicht nur die
waschmaschine sondern eben auch der
trockner geschirrspüler der kühlschrank
da brummt nicht mehr
ich stelle mich jetzt da mal kurz hin
[Musik]
alle ganz leistung
und so weiter
wie komm schon
so lautet hier auf der messe
[Musik]
jedes jahr auf der messe geben uns
diesen stress wir packen jetzt gerade
die tüten ist gudibergs für die
zuschauer
und da haben wir natürlich unsere
partner mit rein machen wir uns helfen
auf jeden fall die kuh libergs haben ich
habe mal reingeschaut wir haben einen
wert von ungefähr 35 bis 40 euro
40 euro sogar das heißt wir haben
ungefähr 400 bis 46 zwischen vier und
sechs stück haben wir
[Musik]
ihr seht hinter mir ist schon alles voll
ist wird es richtig gehen ja der ganze
stand die ganzen neu die waffe schon es
ist unglaublich es ist wahrscheinlich
der meist besuchte stand heute auf der
ifa
und das ist kann es gar nicht erwarten
ich kann ich kann gar nicht sagen ich
will so offen und perplex und wir haben
jetzt sachen vorgebrachten die ganzen
die ganzen gut wie weg gemacht und wir
freuen uns auf die zuschauer auf die
leute die da stehen und werden den
ganzen tag eine richtig coole show
machen das heißt kochen und backen und
alles kostenlos viele leute das essen
und kostenlos die getränke und allem
drum und dran also schon richtig
aufgeregt und agonie und sally und alle
natürlich auch okay
das sehen wir uns gleich herzlich kombis
fällt ja danke schön
ich will mordsmäßig aufgeregt muss ich
ehrlich sagen wie sein team angereist
heute richtig coole sache wir sind sie
schon aufgeregt ich hoffe dass gleich
meine frau kommt dass sie wieder abhauen
kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sorgt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sally app ist jetzt gleich im app
store jetzt erst wir haben euch einen
kleinen trailer vorbereitet
[Musik]
ja alles die app online der wahnsinn ist
wie die app ist in den charts
[Musik]
sie gibt es in echt praktisch input
prozessor von cambridge vier
verschiedenen aufsätzen und das ist
echter erste prozessor dem ich sehe mit
waage funktion
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier oben den
mix behälter also den ganz normalen flug
prozessor den ich zum beispiel auch der
cooking chef habe hier aber wirklich
schön kompakt für eine kleine
arbeitsplatte wenn wir mal eben schnell
aufstieg machen will oder was mixen will
und hier habe ich verschiedene scheiben
das heißt ich kann gemüse obst raspeln
oder hobeln oder ich kann zum beispiel
auch mixa einsätzen für tipps und
aufstriche was der kleine ich habe hier
auch ein stumpfes messer
das heißt ich kann auch dinge einfach
vermengen und das habe ich auch noch nie
gesehen
diese kleinen süßen schnee während bei
diesem mega in seinem vertrag soll
morgen mal eben den aufstrich machen
will setzt sich hier dass mixa ein kann
die zutaten hier einfach schön rein
liegen
so jetzt nicht aber behutsam
geht es hier alles und fertig ich
praktisch und einfach cool das ist echt
komisch
ich bin nur wie wir jetzt mal nicht
schlecht dass oder moral
kann doch fenster essen ist gut gegen
blähungen und die koralle gerade dort
nachtigall es gibt keine heile meisten
kinder ist eine gruppe von weißen den
fenstern chance selbst gegen blähungen
sollte bei mäßigen 12 3 wer weiß das
schon alle sagen gefasst haben sich in
den vorigen global dahin gesagt ich habe
genauso gut in der tür
er hat eure deko weg ist murat ist eure
deckel hab ich echt ok ich hab' die
deckung gegessen
[Musik]
es ist hierbei griff und der gerichte
essen was du tust und alle buchstaben
[Musik]
okay das war jetzt auch und zwar hier
das hätte die becher der drei gehabt
hat er 23 jahre 2 so so
wahnsinn
[Musik]
juni 1,4 und hund habe ich gemacht
juni da musst du gar nicht so schlau
seines blicks auf du hin
wahnsinn so cola kaffee getränken da
kommt so locker machen lassen meinl ob
man auf der hut und ein brennen daher
wirklich gehabt zu jung ist ist da noch
was zu retten war einmal jetzt ob der
was man sich aus also wirst du es nötig
haben
du bist ein bild ist dann halt nicht
ich kenne diese frau die kommt jedes
jahr her ist es jedes jahr machen und
kaufen nichts weil herr minister wo die
so sagt ich habe wissen wovor ich angst
habe dass ich das jetzt jeden morgen
machen muss jaja so ratlos gesehen
also mädels sogar murat schafft hat es
gesehen
ja
perfekt kurator ist kaffee gemacht und
ich habe mich in der zeit steigen lassen
schöne mädchen
echt cool unser kater murat kam
[Musik]
murat murat
wie vor bei für uns jetzt haben unser
kern vielleicht ja
die kulisse kann eine richtig coole
messer sie habe angst das werk homme und
gar nichts innovatives finden weil ich
finde es ist unser krass innovativ habe
ich auch so ein paar highlight für mich
auf jeden fall der erwachsenen tochter
die jetzt eben sagen kann wann das
gericht fertig ist wenn man wirklich
halt immer warten muss stimmen noch ein
highlight war das sportgerät jetzt weiß
ich auch dass sport spaß nach julian
zwar richtig coole sport bewegung und
das a-team ist gerät fertig werdet dein
atem weiterhin kontrollieren und schauen
was zuerst nicht erst
was man einheit also gespannt ist das
ist die welt von rückhand ist hier was
hast du schreiben wollen mit dem schwanz
das war nicht richtig jetzt wird im
nachhinein war es cool wenn werte
zuschauerin gestehen
es wäre super für die leute die die
events haben und zwar dann würde niemals
vergessen die karte zu füttern
ja eine coole sache
dann fand ich richtig cool aber nicht
ist sinnlos aber trotzdem vielfalt
dieses mario kart realist karten
erhalten hat richtig spaß gemacht
deshalb wird der preis 1000 euro obwohl
die meisten haben eine helle sterne so
kam aber richtig genial und ansonsten
war es ist cool dinge aber oftmals auch
wo sich mir dass sich erschließt
waschmaschine der zukunft ist auch polen
diesen eingriff hat der mann kann dann
fragen hey waschmaschine wie muss ich
meinen seiten zeit waschen du kannst du
nichts mehr kaputt also die antwortet er
und alles automatisch alles ist vernetzt
holztag ist wirklich so
manchmal erschrickt einiges aber ich
denke aber wenigstens sinnvoll ist dann
ist es ganz wichtig cool sein und
dennoch es geschafft während der bank
noch mehr als ich kein hand gedreht
hatte
wirklichen maschine
in höheren lagen muss gut über aufmacht
das cool über die efk platz eins
das reicht unser highlight wir haben
youtube weggeschossen whatsapp
weggeschossen und wehrsprecher dienste
rembeck geschossen über zwei alle waren
richtig coole sache und die leute waren
vielen dank an alle besucher an alle die
da waren sagt uns richtig wie geht es ja
auch super viel spaß gemacht und wir
hatten auch wirklich eine schöne zeit
wir sehen uns nichts termin extra wieder
auf die bahn berlin wo genau und wie er
selbst immer nach berlin kommt bitte
nehmt euch ohne spaß mindestens drei
tage zeigen das ist keine ganz ehrlich
bin einen tag braucht nicht kommen
außerdem ein tag an dem genau aber
ansonsten wirklich weiter hinaus sehen
wollt dann kommt zwei drei tage
nein nichts